la situation dans les alpes maritimes
étant hors de contrôle des annonces
étaient attendues ce week-end elles
n'arriveront finalement que ce lundi
matin le préfet prendra la parole dans
la matinée pour dévoiler les mesures
choisies après une longue consultation
avec les élus ce dimanche
de son côté le maire de nice a fait part
sur twitter de son inquiétude face à la
saturation des hôpitaux dans le
département situation sanitaire
catastrophique au niveau départemental
dix-sept nouvelles hospitalisations
depuis ce matin réanimation proche de la
saturation des programmations
d'opérations lourdes au chu de nice tous
les établissements de santé du
département sont concernées transferts
de patients de cannes vers gap et
d'antibes vers l'institut arnault tzanck
et la polyclinique saint-jean faute de
lit on ne peut plus attendre
plusieurs propositions étaient sur la
table des consultations ce dimanche un
confinement le week-end pour les villes
du département située sur le littoral
serait la piste privilégiée des
autorités autre possibilité le
renforcement du couvre feu
l'interdiction d'entrer dans le
département sauf pour motif impérieux ou
encore un confinement généralisée à
l'ensemble des alpes-maritimes
le temps presse dans le sud est le taux
d'incidence y est particulièrement élevé
notamment dans la métropole niçoise avec
plus de 800 cas positifs pour cent mille
habitants
ce dimanche les niçois ne semblait pas
hostile à l'idée d'un nouveau
confinement et coûter jusqu'à présent
les mesures qui ont encore fait à 18
heures on peut pas dire que ça fait
apporter une preuve de sa pertinence
donc ça peut questionner par rapport à
l'efficience des mesures pourraient
peut-être s'entendre mais ça devient
pénible on est aisé on sait pas ce qui
nous attend demain ça peut changer tous
les jours on a envie de se projeter ce à
dire vraiment récession jusque
actuellement c'est des vacances
scolaires donc ça favorise en plus de
tourisme plus important et on le voit
dans la ville que il ya un relâchement
certain de les masquer les gens ne
ressort plus facilement et donc je pense
que c'est vraiment à cause des vacances
scolaires les alpes maritimes pourrait
être le premier département
métropolitain à être mis sous cloche
séparément mais la situation dans le
reste de l'hexagone reste préoccupante
une réunion en visioconférence ce samedi
avec une quinzaine d'élus de la majorité
emmanuel macron vrai déclaré qu'il se
laissait huit à dix jours pour décider
d'un potentiel renforcement des mesures
sanitaires
tendance confirmée par le porte parole
du gouvernement ce dimanche on observe
que depuis deux trois jours le plateau
remonte un peu évidemment que cela doit
nous appeler à nous mobiliser à
continuer à respecter les gestes
barrières pour faire en sorte de
maintenir le niveau des contaminations
au plus bas et si possible de le faire
descendre aujourd'hui la tendance n'est
pas bonne la tendance n'est pas
malheureusement à desserrer les
restrictions et la contrainte et je suis
le premier à le regretter mais il n'y a
pas de fatalité
douze départements dépasse actuellement
le seuil d'alerté maximale parmi eux la
moselle qui inquiète également les
autorités outre-rhin le gouvernement
allemand pourrait classer le département
comme zone à risque dans ce cas chaque
habitant de la moselle devra
obligatoirement présenter un test pcr
négatif de -2 48 heures afin de pouvoir
se rendre en allemagne